any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
but first i want to introduce you to my
audience who might not be familiar with
you
and your name is rose schindler and i'm
convinced we are
related because my grandfather's side
of my family came from unvar from
hungary
20 kilometers from syria yeah it's right
near syrenya
between um serenia was between mumkach
and
far right yes
and then uh and and we have close ties
with you i met you
six years ago with max your beloved
husband a blessed memory
uh and the two of you have been such
deep inspiration to me to my family to
my friends
i could not resist wanting to you know
interview you
and share your wisdom and today is an
appropriate day today is actually
recording this
on uh thursday july 30th which is
the jew in the hebrew calendar it's the
ninth of the month of of
which is known as tish above and it's a
fast day so
i've been fasting i want to talk about
that and talk about
how uh people like me can relate to
to tisha bob through the experiences of
someone like you and max
having been through a literal hell and
uh i want to first i want to take take a
step back
and just and just introduce you know who
you are where you are
where you grew up um i've known you for
for
long enough to be you know so impressed
with you that you're
you're perhaps you know the most the
most courageous individual i've ever met
and i have tremendous respect for you
and
and i hope that when uh i am
even you know a little bit older that i
can have one percent of the energy that
you have
for a mission that if you like god put
you on earth to do which is to tell the
world as
as your father implored you again and
again in your book that you wrote with
max called to her survived
it was a best-selling book came out last
year and
it's been featured around the world and
you've done such tremendous work but
first rose
can you introduce yourself um where you
grew up
and where you live now and uh and then
we'll talk a little bit more about some
of the topics in the book
okay well i was born in czechoslovakia
which is
russia by the way right now or the
ukraine actually
right between alvaro and monkat 20
kilometers on either side
okay anybody wanted to go from
montgomery toward they had to go to
through ceremony because that was the
only road
i come that village we uh there were
about 600 jewish people
in our village okay i don't know if you
call it a village or not
but uh because there are villages many
villages all over
europe three four hundred people okay
so uh we had a wonderful life
because this was austria-hungary before
the first world war
in the second world war it became czech
slovakia and of course in 1938
hitler came into power so hitler and uh
so became hungary again because hungary
wasn't
uh you know friends of hitler okay
so uh before the war everything was
great my father was a tailor he had a
shop in the left town
here you've seen the in the book the
picture
and they said we had a really great life
we never even dreamt of going to america
or going here or there because we didn't
need to do that
i wish we would have family members say
so but in 1938 everything went to hell
when i read the book the book is written
um in sort of real time you're writing
it
as you remembered it and as max
remembered it
and so your husband your late husband um
a blessed memory max schindler
uh so first of all one one misconception
to get out of the way you're not related
to the famous oscar schindler
although you did participate obviously
in the he was he was true
we don't know because they came from the
same town oh they did oh
yes and my uh we believe and my max was
nine years old when they
were pushed out of his town okay
so we believe that they converted
yes that must have had some jewish blood
in him to do what he did
okay and you think about um
you think about the perspective of the
way the book starts
and it's heartbreaking because we know
the outcome
of the story on one hand we know that
you survived i mean that's the title of
the book but we know how many
didn't survive and that's of course what
makes it so noteworthy
uh the way that you tell this true story
from two different perspectives a young
boy a young
woman all the way up through marriage
and then eventually
overcoming but of course the brutal mid
middle part of the book is about your
experience in
auschwitz birkenau too and the camps
that you endured starting in 1944 but
before we get there
i want to first take a step back when
you were a little girl
the stories that you tell rose makes me
want to live
where you were living it makes me it
seems so idyllic
your eight brothers and sisters you were
you had uh
ten f ten uh people in the family your
father had a business
you you worked he worked with jews with
non-jews
he uh he uh and max's family as well but
but specifically yours because i'm
speaking with you today
uh you talk about the rituals your daily
life
um the the just ordinary nature of life
in syrenya and how idyllic it seemed
and until until one day obviously
everything changed
but um when you look back on it i look
back on your life and i see
a vision for how i'd love to have raised
my kids
at least in the very beginning and the
suddenness at which
things change is so startling
unbelievable can you talk about
um how how can the human mind even
process that we live in america the
greatest country in the world
uh the greatest country um you know for
jews
even uh you know aside from israel
that's ever existed and
how is it possible that you know the
world can go
as max talks about he said his father
loved germany so much
that because it was a pinnacle in
science which is what i study
in technology and culture how can how
can the world
go mad so quickly how did you process
that
as a young person well remember i was
like nine years old
ninety when it's all started in 1938
and i i was an ignorant ignorant
ignorant child
you know in those days we were really
not like today today at
10 12 14 year olds they're so grown up
it's not like how we grew up
we didn't know anything what was going
on in the world first of all in 1939
our town was kind of closed off we could
not go anywhere anymore
we had no we didn't have any information
what was going on in the world
because now if anybody had one or two
radios in the whole town
it was against the law there was never
any newspapers and
the only information they would give to
us if there was any
they used to use the drum from middle of
the town from the farmers market they
use the drum
and they would announce different things
what's going on but after 1939 40 none
of this was done
and we had no idea what was going on but
i tell you
as jews in those days we are so
religious believed in god so strong
nobody believed that anything so
horrible was ahead of us
you mentioned that many times how
religious your father was
yeah absolutely strictly orthodox i mean
we had no
idea what was going on and we were
strictly believing in god that
everything
will be fine we were taken like sheep to
the slaughter
[Music]
believable how when you look back on
that
um you know i've reconciled with this
question as well again today is tisha
bob and the jewish calendar which means
it's it's a fast day it commemorates the
destruction of the temple in jerusalem
and
the temple in jerusalem was said to be
destroyed not
because of outside forces the romans or
whatever who literally did the
destruction
can completed the district but because
of baseless hatred that there was hatred
between the jews
and uh and there were times throughout
jewish history
dating back as the as the um
as the the description goes back to the
tale of the spies
in the desert uh you know thousands of
years ago with moses
that um said you know evil things or
told evil things about the nature of the
land and the inhabitants
up until up until the destruction of the
temple
uh but jews have been targeted for so
long and
i wonder you know if if uh i think elie
wiesel said you know
god told the jews they had a mission but
he didn't say it was a suicide mission
do you feel like
this is a pattern in history that is
destined to be repeated or do you feel
like
you know after the holocaust there's no
denying that there's been this awful
oppression not not only of jews but of
tremendous numbers of groups throughout
history do you feel like
it it's come to an end or could it
happen again
who knows what's ahead of us tell me
okay
i sure hope it never happens again you
think the world would have had a good
uh experience what happened and it
i hope it never happens again there's no
reason for that
i mean we as jews in in serena
we had a wonderful life during before
the war
okay we had no problem but we got along
with everybody
only jewish people mostly but business
people
even though we had no higher education
than middle school okay
so if anybody wanted to get higher
education they'd have to go to either
mankato
or budapest or whatever so uh
i just can't believe that the world
allowed this to happen
everybody was silent and they took us
like
sheep to the slaughter okay nobody tried
to help us
and i sure hope it never happens again
okay
and we'll get to your mission um towards
the end of the conversation
uh to to bring the attention
to the world as your father said you had
to survive
and if you didn't you know the world
would not know your story
and it was almost as if you had a divine
mission and i and i feel like
i wonder how many roses there could have
been or max's there could have been
that that didn't make it out uh mainly
only because of you know this horrible
term we call luck you know that they
just didn't have it or
perhaps you you had so many examples in
the book
um which is is just so so gripping
i mean i read it in a couple of hours
and and
i love learning about max and i just
regret that i didn't have as much time
with him as
as i do with you and hopefully you'll
live to 120 and
will have many chances to to have more
conversations as you know
you're the uh my one of my daughters her
her middle name is rose
in your honor uh our little our little
baby and
beautiful children ah thank you rose
thank you um
but when i think about you i think about
this this
courage that you had that you had this i
think of you
very interestingly because you have
tremendous courage you can be very
serious but you have a sense of humor
that is is just so endearing and i
wonder
where did you get that that spirit of of
courage that spirit of i am going to
find a way to succeed that you could
succeed
literally in the depths of hell that you
stepped out of lines that would have led
to your slaughter and
and how did you come how did you what
what caused you to have that courage you
don't speak as much about your mother
uh in the book was it her i mean your
father obviously was this towering
intellect this figure of religious
pillar in your life but
where did you get the the other side of
you the mischievous side the
the the side that took risks and and had
such great courage i was a comp
tom boy growing up
yeah many times i would do things i
shouldn't do
and got spanked for it but uh
i need i'm i was not ready to take
anything that's
ahead of me i had to fight it my father
you know i saw my father in camp the
group was
selected already and they were there
temporarily in
camp c and auschwitz and he
we met the next morning okay in
auschwitz and he said whatever you do
stay alive so you can tell the world
what they're doing
and i stuck to that and believe me many
times i was
i was taken i was
selected to go to out to the concentrate
to the
excuse me to the oven because you know
we
they brought us there to do work slave
labor okay and we would have selections
all the time
so uh the first three four times of
selections
they would put me in the gas chamber
line because i was skin and bone i was
never
a heavy person and being in auschwitz
like 10 days before we decided hey we
need to get out of this god forsaken
place
okay so we went for selection
three four times and then each time they
put us in the gas gym and
they put me in the gas chamber line and
my two sisters into the
center factory to work so you know you
get a lot of
uh knowledge when you're in a place like
this
people tell you how to survive okay
you talk so much in the book about how
aside from the awful you know german um
the uh german guards that were there
most of the
people in charge so to speak were jewish
and and
how did you relate to that how could you
process that that these were your fellow
jews and they were they were kind of
orchestrating
and playing a role obviously they were
forced at death at the
pain they had no choice so you didn't
you didn't harbor any resent against the
capos because
they are perceived you know there is
literature about them as
sort of you know um mixed literature
shall we say
but you don't harbor any any resentment
or hatred towards no no
listen the man that came on the train to
help with my luggage she was one of our
survivors and he comes and tells me he
says how old are you i said i'm 14 he
just tell him you're 18.
so a lot of people were saved that way
okay
and if you hadn't been uh told that you
would have said you're 14
and you couldn't be here you wouldn't be
here no
i would have gone they won't they told
me to go with my you know
of course they asked me my age and i
said i was 18 and my sister helen said
oh no she's only 14 i said oh no i'm 18.
i don't know what made me say that i had
no idea what's going on
so remember this was the beginning of
auschwitz too
because we got there in what so
you get a lot of advice from your people
that you're willing
about these things and it's almost the
information
denial to you know the uncertainty the
the
the the lack of knowledge about your
fate and the rumors and the
misinformation
even knowing what what happened with the
benefit of history that i
do know about what this tragic event was
and
really just awful evil event um
series of events that happened to you
and to max and
uh and then realizing that you know part
of it was to strip you of your dignity
and your humanity and i don't i wonder
you know if it would even be possible
if the germans didn't do this if they
didn't shave your heads and
and give you no clothes and make you
stand in pointless lines and
and assemble every morning for counting
that that was part of the strategy it
wasn't enough that you would die
that the jews would be killed it was
they had to be humiliated
they had to be um tortured
psychologically
and i wonder you know i've often heard
you know these these the you know by
people i love
that the nature of humanity is good i
i wonder do you agree with that or i'm
not saying that humans are inherently
evil by any means god forbid but
do you feel like humans have a natural
inclination
one way or another or do you think it's
just random chance
well i think it depends on circumstances
what what you have to do and what you
need to do
the germans they had no choice okay even
though i'm sure a lot of them wouldn't
have wanted to do what they were doing
but they did what they had to do
and uh of course a lot of them did
a lot more conditions should also all
right
so there were never any germans that
would help us
and we never even expected that but
anyway the thing is
uh all we had to do is just
believe in god and not give up hope
that's another thing
every day we would say don't ever give
up hope make
remember tomorrow will be better what
was the hope about rose was it that
god would rescue you was it that you
could escape was it that
hitler would be killed hoping that the
war would end
okay this is 1944. you know by the time
we came to auschwitz probably my
my town my village was liberated in
september of 1944
just five months after we were taken
away so we were
about we were i was we were four months
in ashes because
every time they would come for people to
go to factories to work
the first couple of months we did it but
then i every time they put me in the gas
chamber line so we decided not to do it
and we were hoping the war would end
we would be liberated okay so because
you know every every barrack has a
thousand women
they come for two three hundred women
you're not forced to go to
line up and get but of course a lot of
us tried
and a lot believe me a lot of people
went into the gas chambers through that
too
okay because people just food was
unbelievable
it was not livable not even for animals
okay
and i i just think you know as you say i
i don't think i could handle
what you went through just being honest
with you and then it even even
just your surviving it was more that i i
would say
in addition to surviving you you had
this attitude that you looked at things
wherever you could as as a chance as an
opportunity
for hope in particular like you make up
that you know and i
i know that your your stature physically
is not as imposing as your as your you
know kind of character
that you're you're such a larger than
life figure but in reality
you're about five feet tall or so maybe
five one i would say
i don't i don't think that's right
um and yet you even say things in the
book like you were
because you were so small they would
give you a stool
and that allowed you not to have to
stand like you're seeing the good
fortune that you had at every turn i
wonder is that because
you know were you so young that you
really didn't have an experience i mean
this is this is five of the worst months
of any human being's life that they
could
possibly endure and it wasn't like when
you got to the work camp
later it was all fun and games it was
still pretty awful it just
the constant threat of being gassed
wasn't quite as high but
when you went to the work camp after and
when was that was that in september
yes and you went to the work camp no
idea about dates by the way
right yeah they denied you that
information all we had
in our lives was a dress and clogs and
that's it
a dress a piece of rag actually okay
so we had no idea but the thing is
you just have to have you had to have
hope if you gave
hope you have you're gone what was the
um you know kind of the hardest time was
it the first days you got there was it
getting towards the end when it seemed
like things
when was it most challenging for you
personally
well the best time was when we were
liberated of course
when we the first four months in
auschwitz working out
camp c was a horrible horrible place
it's a transitional camp you come
and you get selected and nobody stays
there like we did
the only people that stayed behind were
the people that were not selected
like me if a lot of people did the same
thing i do okay
because we're hoping the board would end
and but of course it took
the world a long time to do that but we
just never gave up hope that's the thing
if you give up hope you're lost okay
and were there people in the uh
in the in the camps that were that
maintain their religiosity that's
remained you know kind of you couldn't
remain
religion i mean we had
all we had to do is worry about
surviving okay
in terms of their faith that people keep
their faith
hope you don't have hope otherwise
you're lost
you give up your home people would put
their hands on the electric fences
20 seconds later they were down dead you
can't imagine how hard they looked
do you think was most max raised by more
religious parents or less religious
people no no no they were like
like reformed jews here in the united
states okay
even though uh they were not orthodox
but they still went to temple
okay so no they were not orthodox
they were very modern religious german
jews
okay and then they were more they they
view germany as sort of a
paradisical place at least until the
awful events that max describes and you
describe
um do you feel like people that were
religious had
uh a better probability does it to
survive
or do you feel like it was it was almost
random that
no matter how religious you were it
didn't it didn't affect your
your chances to survive i don't think so
i don't know we never talked about
religion
anybody can because we're always
hoping that tomorrow will be better
we're hoping
we're going to get liberated okay
because if you don't hope you're lost
okay remember anybody that has any
problems
remember hoping uh that tomorrow is
going to be better that's how is it
that's how we survive and do you think
because the holocaust is so
difficult for a human being to relate to
uh do you feel like that advice can even
translate into
today when we're dealing with covid or
something like that is there
is this just so far removed from an
experience that is relatable in any way
to modern human beings
uh that are living in a civilized
society
do you think that the the the lessons of
the holocaust are so unique to that
form of unique evil or do you feel like
there is lesson to be learned from from
the holocaust that we could apply
towards people that are going through a
horrible
a mental anguish physical anguish today
obviously not the hands of human beings
but at the hands of this invisible awful
pandemic
i sure hope nobody ever has to go
through what we went through
this this is unbelievable what happened
to us
okay and the thing is
uh if if you really have a terrible
terrible time
you need to fight back and not ever give
up hope and make sure that they just
don't take you like sheep to the
slaughter okay
stand up for your rights we all have the
same rights
whether you're jewish or catholic or
whatever
religion we all have the same rights in
this world and we have to stand up for
our rights
okay but uh i don't know if there
was i don't know what else we could have
done we tried so hard to survive this
you have no idea
people died like ants i mean i don't
know if you've ever been to auschwitz
i have not no i have not i wanted to go
okay uh we've been there in in 95
okay and uh so
um and actually we were we were there
for the seven years anniversary of
liberation of auschwitz also
we were supposed to go i was supposed to
go with my kids in january
right before january uh i came out with
a
pot what do you call it uh i had to have
surgery
yeah all right you had a heart um a
pacemaker
just happened new year's couple of days
after new year's
and you still wanted to go down to
for the trip we canceled i just i was
afraid uh that i would
ruin everybody's trip because many my
kids went
okay ruin everybody's like trip okay
yeah so we decided i decided i'm not
going so then my daughter says she's not
going either
but two of my sons and some of my
grandkids went hmm
wow and on that day of the pleasant
place to go to by the way
no no but do you think it should be kept
it should be preserved obviously
absolutely never should not forget what
happened to us and so it should never
happen again this is unbelievable that
the world allowed this to happen
and you know the united states they did
not do anything to help us either
so many people had papers to come to
america during the war
and they were all denied my husband's
family had papers to go to the united
states
didn't make it and you talk about in the
book
you know the feeling of of you know just
just
relief of of joy obviously that was
tempered by the realization that your
father and and many of your siblings
didn't
survive obviously um and um
and just wanted to go back to this to
the liberation the commemoration day and
uh this year of the 75th anniversary so
actually that day i was talking to
another jewish woman her name is
um dr jessica meer and she was in space
she was floating around in space on the
space station on the
on the day that commemorates the 75th
anniversary of the liberation of
auschwitz
and i just thought how amazing it is
that you know who would have predicted
that
you know 75 years earlier or 76 years
earlier
that such a thing could be possible to
literally you know reach the highest
heights and
and i wonder you know if if part of your
mission now obviously
is is not to is to tell the world you
realize that
you had to do your dad gave you this
mission your tata
gave you a mission to to do something
but
even those that survived that that had
hope or
kept it they have not been able to uh
for for reasons that are totally
understandable maybe not wanting to deal
with it
yeah it seems like you were able to deal
with it as your son
i guess it was steve was it steve that
had to do a report
on anne frank's uh diary
a play right so can you tell what
happened next what how did that then
uh um encourage you to start sharing
your story
in at that time we never talked about
the holocaust
first of all my kids were too young we
wanted to forget the past
we had better things to do so when steve
was 13 years old he was at lu
um he was junior high and he was in the
and drank play
he played the part of peter the teacher
found out that his parents are holocaust
survivors
that's when i started speaking before i
had not in
i did not have any imagination about
talking about the past
because it was not a pleasant thing for
us okay
so lewis junior high was the first place
where i
spoke so and after that
i started speaking and i've been
speaking ever since
and steve is 61 years old wow
and it's important for us to tell the
world what happened to us so it
shouldn't happen again
okay yeah you say in the book after my
presentation to steve's class
the children started to write
compassionate letters to me
they touched me to my core i realized
that innocent children are helping to
mend my heart with kindness
they also speak of a desire to change
the world to prevent problems that could
lead to something as horrific as the
holocaust and a need to work together
if children can learn these powerful
lessons from my experiences
they can change the world can you say
how that thing shifted in you and can
you talk about
do you know how many students you've
spoken to in the past
several thousands thousands you know
it's really a funny thing this week
since i'm
since we're all home and we have so many
things in the homes that we never
touched for years and years
i went and one of my closets
full closet is full of letters from the
children wow
schools wow so a couple of days ago i
took
all these letters and all these bags
and i found a and i got a big box and i
put all that and put it in the garage
in this closet for other things so oh no
i have oh my god i've been speaking for
close to 50 years okay the schools the
week before this disease came out
i spoke five times a week sometime even
on weekends and sometimes even in the
evenings evenings to women's
organizations and
you know so yeah that's how we met we
met
at a small gathering just a private kind
of dessert gathering
in la jolla as i said about five or six
years ago when when max was here
uh and uh and i remember you know just
not wanting it to end and and just
hearing this conversation
and thinking back you know i just had
this incredible desire i wanted to do
something i want to do something and i
didn't know what i could do
and i hoped that you'd write a book but
i didn't know that you were going to
write a book
and how did this idea come to you and
max um
uh obviously you know he the book is
written from both of your perspectives
so it's kind of this
it's kind of this unique uh description
i haven't read any book like this where
there's two
perspectives but it's unfolding in real
time
and you feel the emotions that you felt
it's really
quite an amazing accomplishment had the
idea to write a book which i am
so grateful that you did write how did
that come come to you
it's been on my mind for many years okay
but max never wanted to do it not his
idea
okay even i mean when we were speaking
at schools max was speaking too but
he always said rose i don't want to do
what you do
you do what you want but uh occasionally
he did speak at schools also
and he wasn't in for stuff like you know
we're all into different things
so i mean it's been on my mind for many
years and then finally after
uh max passed actually one day while i'm
speaking at a school
um one of the people that came one of
the
mothers of the children came to listen
to me speak
she's the one with my book she never
wrote the book before
no okay wow and
after max passed away as i said i did
have on my mind to someday write a book
after max passed away uh this lady came
to
call me she says rose let's write the
book
she came to my house and we wrote the
book it took about six months
to get it all done and
there it is no it's an incredible the
world needs to know what happened to us
even though there's
many other people have wrote books too
no but this is a unique book because of
the fact that it's the two of you and
that you you
weave together this uh this true story
from two different
vantage points in that the world could
you know
maybe i couldn't relate to a little
girl's experience but i can relate to a
little boy's experience or whatever
and so in that sense i don't think
there's any book comparable to it and
the photographs in it um you know the
way i remember max as just this
joyous uh joyous man and by the way this
would have been
this past week would have been your
anniversary is that right the 27th
27th 70th anniversary of our
marriage oh wow yeah
he was such a let me tell you it's so
awful to be alone
i was never alone because i met max in
the hostel
you know when i was 16 years old
the only man in my life
and he's such an amazing individual when
he i remember hearing from him
when we met many years ago that he
always had this desire for education for
technology
and he was really self-made i mean he
you guys came to america with what 20
you got 20 when you arrived and then you
immediately went to work
uh until one day you collapsed and and
fainted on the floor i think of a subway
when you were pregnant with roxanne
and uh and then he had you know and he
ended up coming to california and just
to hear the way that he describes
the pride that he felt that he could
learn a trade that he could learn a
skill
coming from nothing from a boy who had
zero potential and
and could have died many times education
or four years of education
and you diminish your education but rose
you speak what five or
you spoke five or six different
languages a lot of languages but now i'm
down to
uh i still speak a hungarian i speak a
dish okay
hungarian uh you couldn't tell me in
russian
but still you it takes a special brain
to do that and also to
run run a business as you ran a business
for many years in san diego and but just
to see max and that he would learn a
trade he would learn computers he did
insurance he did
all sorts of different trades and he
would do it at night uh
he wanted to be he said in the book and
i really welled up with
pride and emotion for him he didn't want
a handout he didn't he wanted to be
independent even if that meant you know
yes
paying you know 20 a month for for an
apartment but he was going to earn it
and he was going to support his bride
in america and that they says anything
was possible in america
and all you have to have is willing to
do it
okay well i worked in the garment
industry
very well okay so
uh of course after five years we decided
max came to san diego to visit one of
his
friends who you know all the boys had to
report to the military
yeah it's here in san diego henry so uh
he came to san diego for a three day
weekend christmas eve 1955.
was it 55 i think so another okay
he never came back to new york he calls
me two days laters rose
pick up and we already had a daughter
yeah
and we're moving to california
yeah and even fast and i just went along
you know
yeah and you made a wonderful life here
and you remember
raise your children here and um and i
think you know
just the simple things that you couldn't
have imagined in the depths of despair
in the in the pits of of of of evil in
auschwitz um and uh theresenstat
and i wonder you know could i just feel
the
um the emotion the pride that he when he
talks about buying his first car
okay it was a used forward but but he
had pride like you never would have
predicted that you never would have
predicted the things that you've seen
and and done and accomplished and um
and i wonder if god didn't put you here
for that mission
that the two of you should meet who
knows
who knows
i mean things are not like they were in
europe with the religion
okay because i was so disappointed what
happened to us
i i still i still ask questions where
was god when this was going on
okay because i was a complete family we
must have had
probably i would say at least 150 to 200
people in our family with my
mother's sisters and brothers my
father's cousins aunts grandparents
and maybe a dozen of us came back after
the boy
when you found i have a lot of questions
to god
i'm sure you do rose and it's totally
natural and i have questions too
even not having gone through what you
went through and max went through
and you know we can't understand it and
i dislike it when people say oh the
reason
the reason for this was so that israel
could be found i reject that i don't i
don't i don't
i reject that too i don't think that's a
good reason okay
i see that that there are special human
beings that are
created and and just as you can ask you
know where was god when
these awful things happened and evil
things happened they were committed by
human beings
um and and you can say that you know
kovid wasn't created
by a human being it's a natural process
let's ignore that for a second
but just think that sometimes when i
meet somebody like you
or and i or i meet my new baby
for the first time and i think um how
how how can you explain it as an as an
atheist you know
the miracles that there are in life that
you did
yeah absolutely a lot of everything is a
miracle
bit all still here okay but anyway
we needed a miracle but we didn't have
it when we needed it
yeah i want to just conclude by uh
discussing
the um the the mission that you're on
now on a read the the
the a couple of sentences from the final
chapter the epilogue
uh so rose and max continued to be
members of the 45
aid society this group maintained
relationships with european survivors
so there were significant numbers or how
many san diegans were
holocaust survivors back when you were
here quite a big group
really yeah going 56 wow
we had the new life club it started in
1949 because a lot
some boys ended in san diego because
they were
in the military okay max was not in the
military because he has he was a
fortress
because he had diseases in the camp
so we started the club in 1949 uh
with a few people and little by little
people were coming we had over 100
members
wow survivor members okay today the club
is still existing and of course a lot of
them are
we we just have maybe 20 25 at a meeting
but most of those are people have that
left the war
before uh they left europe before the
war
so they're still considered survivors
but there's not too many
real survivors like me left in san diego
anymore
so i was 14 when we were taken away okay
so um
max told me when uh a few years ago
that he had a friend who would survive
the camps with him
and that he was drafted and served in
korea is is that true
i not sure about korea but he was in the
military
i think that that and then he almost
died in korea
and the thing i mean i can't even
envision that imagine surviving
hell on earth and then coming to america
and thinking your life is
is completely changed obviously and then
being drafted
to go and fight thank god he survived uh
but it's just it's just an
unbelievable story of the and many i
know many of the survivors did want to
serve and repay america
some of them also were killed okay i
mean actually this is after the war so
there was no war when they went into the
military
but some probably may have had some
diseases maybe
that they never knew about it and some
of them may have died
but actually even if they didn't go into
the military
some of us some survivors did not live
as long as what
i'm still around at 90. it's a miracle
that i'm still around you are yeah
well you're believe i would live that
long i know especially with
everything that you described my husband
was with me for
67 years wow and he was such a
an amazing inspiration from for me just
to see
i mean if you met max you would you if
you meet
rose to my listener you'll know soon
what she
what she is about that what she has gone
through what she has
recovered from what she has accomplished
and and
and just just dominated you know life
and just
sucks out the mayor of but max was a
little bit more introverted max was
reserved
but um being in the presence of him was
uh like being with a very quiet sort of
saintly
person and that he was um
he was he was so uh he had a sense of
calm about him
that was very unusual i mean i love
talking to you you and i are family
members i'm sure
and so we just relate to each other but
max was this um and i wonder if it was
this german you know kind of upbringing
but he was very stoic in a sense
he was a very smart man yes he was three
and a half years of education in schools
if he would have if not for the world he
would have been something very special
yeah on a long way okay
but he was not a speaker like me no he
enjoys speaking like ice
i speak to everybody i go outside out of
my house and i start talking to all the
neighbors
especially in this time we're all
outside
walking we've never done unbelievable
over 50 years now and i think
last night i went out for a walk and i
happened to take two books with me
okay and by the time i was done
i left without the books
i mean it's amazing we start talking to
every to each other
and the world the whole world is getting
a lot finer
yeah and i think about the um as you
talk about in the book the
other projects you're involved with the
butterfly project
um which is to be active oh
shadow price i met charlotte president
she was working on that
oh wow oh i know the beginning
she's a really nice lady and um and
nowadays you've
obviously spoken to to thousands of
people you participated in the
usc showa foundation institute with
steven spielberg who documented the
testimonials
of the holocaust um and that the
the the project obviously culminated or
is related to schindler's list the film
in uh the other awards that you've
received are jewish heritage month local
heroes award from kpbs
rose was named one of the cool women of
2015 by the san diego girl scouts
as well as a woman of valor during the
24th annual lipinski jewish arts
festival in san diego in 2017.
two years ago you were awarded an
honorary high school diploma from a la
jolla country day school
and an honorary mba oh so maybe you can
help me with my tactics i'm an educated
people person you are well yes
not all educations come with such uh
such very impressive curriculum
vitae and senior class unanimously voted
to award rose
the shin uh the certificate after
hearing
her speak at their school she was
interviewed on both days and
with a big smile she told the reporters
this is the best day of my life
well um rose i do want to thank you i'm
gonna
i'll end the podcast for us and then i
wanna i'll call you back
and then i want you to say hi to little
uh little uh miriam rose my daughter
who's
uh who's named after you and what she
wants to say hi to you so
uh rose i want to thank you so much uh
and my audience sorry this is you know a
little bit different from the scientists
the engineers the how long have you been
doing this
i've been doing this for almost two
years maybe but uh
but you're the you're just such a you're
the most special guest i've had
you did this well we've been on a couple
of other podcasts by the way i don't
know if you know that
yes i do i know you were on a very very
well-known one with a local san diegan
named jaco willink and that has seen
over a quarter million views so i'm
gonna put that in the link
in the notes for people that are
listening uh to see rose who's this five
foot
uh one inch uh domina a mighty you know
indomitable spirit
next to jocko willing who's like six
feet and huge muscle man navy seal
uh commander very nice guy very
brilliant guy too so
i'll put a link to that um and rose i
just wanna i just wanna thank you
uh i think about you all the time our
family loves you
and we're so glad that you i love you
guys i love your children they're so
cute
they love you they really worship you
and uh and i know that we'll be together
soon i want everybody to be healthy
yes she is too so i want to thank you so
much rose
and uh thanks to your your children for
setting this up and
um i hope we can see each other soon one
way or another
right right thank you for doing this
brian
thank you rose you're you're a true
child well stay healthy
thanks you've heard it here don't don't
ignore it put your mask on i
walk out and i forget to put my mask at
a mask listen to rose she knows what
she's talking about
thank you rose
so
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric vieri director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valgo